speaking of food um a lot of people come
here or at least a lot of anime come
anime fans come here expecting to uh
enjoy like the weeb aspect and then
pretty much everyone i talk to they come
to japan and they're just like i stay
for the food oh yes the food culture
come for the anime yeah yeah yeah right
right you spend your money on food if
you're gonna spend your money on
something i i know it's going to be hard
walking through akihabara and you can
see some cool anime figures spend your
money on a good meal you will not
[ __ ] regret it it'll be the best meal
you've probably had in your entire life
yeah what what kind of things you guys
recommend people try out when they're
here not ichiran not each one right
now no no
go to
wherever you are
find the filthiest grossest looking
ramen place yes most likely the ramen
will be a 10 out of 10. yes
i mean it's you know no it's always no
no it's never a one it's never a one the
ones that
the ones that have the [ __ ] neon
signs look really pretty on the outside
they're just covering the fact that
their food is made yeah and the thing is
it might look intimidating because
obviously it looks very traditional you
don't know how to order most of the time
it there will be a machine right like a
machine like a ticket machine and all
you have to do is put your money in and
uh if you're having trouble you know
figuring out
uh what the orders are because there's
normally like only like four ramens to
choose from anyway so that's the good
places yeah those are the good places
the less choice you have on the menu the
more like the better chance it's going
to be that is going to [ __ ] bomb
because it's like it's
uh because that that means that this
family or the the person running the
restaurant has just like perfected their
car they've perfected it they've
sharpened their craft you know
um but most of the time you're only
gonna have like three or four ramens to
pick from you can like use the [ __ ]
google translate thing uh
hack that uh
life hack that we use um if you're
having trouble but it's not it's really
not that um intimidating at all so you
just choose you choose your meal maybe
you go with the gyoza as well maybe you
order beer with it um and then you just
give your tickets to the ramen guy and
he'll give you your order that's pretty
much it and it's the bit and it's
probably the best [ __ ] ramen you'll
ever have in your life yeah honestly uh
like we just said earlier convey about
sushi uh i actually prefer conveyor belt
sushi a lot of the times to the more
expensive sushi chains and sushi
restaurants i think i think it depends
for me like i i don't mind going to the
more expensive ones maybe like once or
twice a year
but if i just want like a consistently
like good
sushi then yeah there's nothing wrong
because there's a lot of places that are
just like lunch sets that are like 2 000
yen and you get like a bunch of stuff no
that's true because you're like right in
front of you here's the reason why like
because with conveyor belt sushi like
it's
such a good value for money yeah and i
remember the first time coming to japan
and just thinking like the sushi is
amazing because it [ __ ] is amazing i
wanted to stuff myself full with as much
sushi as i could eat and you can't do
that with expensive changes
yeah i prefer the ones with the conveyor
belts but you order and then it comes
out on the conveyor belt that's most
places now yeah yeah i know there are
still some that have like the rotating
ones oh yeah yeah it's just like i would
rather have the freshly prepared one
yeah yeah
yeah so with a lot of conveyor belt
brands or places that we that you go to
um they'll have a system where some of
them some of them will literally like be
automated where they'll have a plate
that gets like shot to you on like a
[ __ ] and yeah the first thing is
usually yeah it's usually shaped like a
bullet train yeah yeah yeah right it's
like so thematically [ __ ] cool it's
so cool it's so cool and uh yeah like i
to this day i still
i still eat as much conveyorable sushi
as i can because i think it's [ __ ]
amazing and i love i love stuffing
myself forward sushi and i can't do that
at more expensive restaurants i mean
sushi's good sushi's good but at the end
of the day it's just fish rice wasabi
right it's fish fries from wasabi and i
also think you should try the
foreign food here
like try to see what their takes are on
uh foreign foods it's quite interesting
they do some really good foreign food
here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah don't be
surprised italian food especially time
food's really good here's some good
really good
uh italian food in europe it's really
good though like imagine that you know
that some some restaurants combine the
techniques of uh you know
italian chefs but use japanese
ingredients which uh is can be really
[ __ ] impressive
uh it's maybe not the most authentic
thing but you get something new
especially the fish here yeah yeah oh my
god fish dishes in japan and italian
food are like next [ __ ] levels yeah
definitely holy [ __ ] the best kind of
fusion oh so what do you think about
them trying wagyu beef yeah try it try
it i mean you know
the thing is there's so many different
types of wagons when you've lived here
long enough i feel like you you kind of
go off wagyu yeah you're like i kind of
want more meat than fat yeah but the
first time you have it it's like a like
a [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] this is an
explosion in your mouth
of all that flavor it's food wars it's
based on like yeah pretty much yeah
you're eating wagyu your mouth is just
like where's like the best place to get
wagyu if you don't know what you're
looking for though
that's really hard yeah go anywhere in
kobe i guess and just get kobe beef
there well let's let's let's assume like
every single prefecture in japan like we
have our own beef that is just good i
think i think in takayama is probably
the best like type of wagyu i've had
right um kobe beef is like
it's good but it's so fatty at times
where you're just like oh my god i don't
know if i'm eating like a piece of fat
or not yeah you're just eating butter
basically yeah basically you just
americans you love that you'd love that
right yeah americans love it like
tepanyaki you always get like you can
always get like wagyu yeah yeah
taponyaki's pretty it also just depends
on how it's prepared as well a lot of
times but like what i really like about
like hideo for example is that like they
literally just like put a bunch like
cubes over basically just on a stick put
it on top of a fire just put some salt
and pepper on that [ __ ] and boom it's
like the best [ __ ] food you'll ever
have and they sell it as street food i
mean chris's favorite food yakitori as
well yakitori is good
again like
kind of wrong do you feel like the best
types of yakitori are the all you can
eat ones or do you think they should go
to like a more traditional yakitori
place i think both are pretty good i
think if it's the first time you're
experiencing that you're probably not
going to be able to taste the difference
i think the only ones who are like you
know go only opt to go to like say the
more traditionalist ones yeah the ones
who have just had so much [ __ ] tori
kizoku that they just like all right let
me just try and be you know
if you really want to try those kind of
place though you really need to do need
to learn the names though yes yes yes
because a lot of those places don't have
a menu no they're giant oh yeah that's
true because they just you just walk up
it's literally just a counter and a dude
standing there just infinitely cooking
chicken and you just have to say that
just say negima that's the best one is
the best one
it's the og yeah it's just chicken with
some leek oh [ __ ] lovely dude
so good
the layers dude they taste so good japan
does niggy based food so well oh dude
it's so good yeah it's really really
good i can just plow down on like 50
like negatives yeah i just i guess
chris always wants the sugar i i think
sukunis just i love to get other
meatballs yeah
i love it i love it like why bastardize
this this chicken dude just give me the
bastardize the chicken rip it apart and
shove it back together talking about it
just grind it apart and make it into a
ball that's great it's just like it's
not the only time i will accept boneless
chicken
[ __ ]
the perfect balance between meat and veg
right you get one bite of chicken and
veg right yeah perfect soup in it pure
like just ground meat and i'm like this
is too much but like i like that because
it's it more evenly spreads the
seasoning right because it's it's
seasoned in the ground meat right
i mean i i just i kind of want a
variation you know
well you know that's the great thing
about yakitori
pork belly as well if uh
in japanese
yeah that's right is really good yeah
um yeah i mean that's the like you get
you that's what i order if i don't want
to have something like wagyu beef but
you still want that like explosion of
like flavor in your mouth like it's like
that perfect cube of like pork belly and
fat right getting [ __ ] hungry i know
i really like like now that we're just
talking about 20 kids
i'm ready to smash down
i'm i've been very hungry this time